i'm tired of having glasses i need to
get lasik has anybody had lasik and if
you did what was the experience like
what's going on guys this is rob
and before we get into this video uh we
don't know who it was that designed this
we'll link the tweet down in the in the
description but like whoever designed
this spider-man costume
it looks amazing right like it looks so
good uh if you know who it was let us
know down in the comments man because
that costume is dope right it just it
looks so awesome
anyway
apparently the spider-man 3 far from
home
no way home
far from being no way home the trailer
has apparently
leaked now
we need to temper expectations here
right we need to temper expectations
because you know we're fans you know we
get ourselves amped up i gotta be honest
with you guys i can't think of the last
time that a movie was made released by
the mcu that's had this much hype and
speculation surrounding it i can't i
can't think of a time when that happened
right it's just
i don't know man because most of the
movies have been straightforward but
like i mean you this has taken on a life
of its own man like it's
it's an exciting time
y'all feel the excitement i know y'all
feel the excitement y'all are like yeah
man
y'all are going straight dean kane i
totally get it right now here's what i
mean to say when i say we need to temper
our excitement here a couple things to
know one if this if this really is the
trailer obviously it's leaked it kind of
looks like booty cheeks it's sort of
hard to figure out exactly what's going
on but there were a few key scenes that
stood out to me and the second thing is
the statement that kevin foggy made to
empire magazine recently now going
verbatim here what kevin feige said was
this rumors are fun because many of them
are true and many of them are not true
the danger is when you get into the
expectations game of wanting people to
be excited about the movie they get and
not disappointed about a movie they
don't get now what feige really seems to
be saying here is that yes there's a lot
of anticipation about this movie yes
there's a lot of rumors flying around is
entirely possible most of them are wrong
and that when we get into the movie that
if we go in there with the expectation
that all the rumors we've heard are true
that it would basically disappoint us
but i gotta be honest man if this leaked
trailer really is
the final trailer
it's everything we hoped for okay uh
roll it right alex my editor roll the
trailer and then we'll talk about it
afterwards
[Music]
cannot defeat them alone
no it's not
[Music]
number four
real identity of spider-man a high
school kid in queens named peter parker
stop talking my name is matthew murdock
i'm your attorney
okay so there were a few things that
stood out to me number one a lot of
people are saying it's fake a lot of
people are saying this is not the actual
real trailer it's a fake trailer right
so i do want to make sure that you go
into this understanding that is that
it's entirely possible that it's fake
right somebody just kind of staged the
whole thing there is an audience in the
background kind of cheering but i mean
that's pretty easy to fake somebody even
said there was a playstation ps4 scene
in it right so nonetheless i will say
if that is a fake trailer it's one of
the best fake trailers that i think i've
ever seen in my life right so the scene
where the portal opens and doctor
strange comes out and like you have toad
maguire and andrew garfield spider-man
on each side and he tells peter you
can't do it alone that scene makes sense
right it makes sense that doctor strange
would do that why because if these
really are the villains as we seem to
know they are that are coming from
basically the sam raimi and the andrew
garfield spiderman film universes
they're the ones who know how to beat
them and so if for some reason these
villains were yanked into the mcu but
the spider-men were left behind that if
peter parker faces off against these
guys by himself has never met them
before has no idea what their strengths
and weaknesses are and if it really is a
sinister six-s scenario where he's
facing off against seemingly all of them
at the same time of course he would get
wrecked so it would make sense that
doctor strange would go to those
universes grab those spider-men bring
them back and then have them all team up
because those guys know how to defeat
their villains that andrew garfield
knows how to beat electro that toby
maguire knows how to beat sandman and
the green goblin and doctor octopus so
we know those things are there assuming
that like the rhino actually had any
real measure of influence on andrew
garfield's spider-man then like he would
know how to beat him too but the
important thing here is that we know
that these villains have faced off
against those spider-men so it would
make perfect sense that doctor strange
would grab those spider-men and bring
them into the mcu to help tom holland
defeat these guys now there are a couple
other scenes that look cool even though
they don't really seem to have any
significance like
all three of them together
teaming up against electro
which looks awesome
[Laughter]
all three of these spider-man teaming up
to fight electro it looks cool it's like
a split second right you don't really
get to see a whole lot there but then
apparently there's another scene where
two of the three spider-man are swinging
through new york and i gotta be honest
man i feel like if that's really true
and that's really what's gonna happen
then he would just make this cohesive
amazing moment you know what i mean were
you just like yeah man like you just get
excited they're literally just swinging
through buildings but you're like yeah
it's the best action i've seen in a long
time spiderman swinging together through
buildings and waving at people it's
amazing
it's just one of those things where it's
just cool to see and that's really all
it is right i mean when it comes down to
stuff like this it's just stuff that's
cool to see but if it really okay if
this trailer really is legit the the
post credit scene for the trailer i
guess we can call it that that looks the
coolest because you've got that scene
where like uh where where j jonah
jamison you have the voiceover of him
like you know you know spider-man killed
mysterio yeah yeah you guys know that
from from far from home and it shows
peter parker basically sitting in jail
and then while he's being interrogated
by that cop matt murdock busts in and
says stop talking i'm your lawyer and
then it ends and it's just like
man i will that's why i say man if this
really is a fake trailer it was
phenomenally put together i'm inclined
to believe that it's real it looks real
like it looks like it is the actual
final trailer for spider-man no way home
and and if it is man
god it looks amazing because it looks
like everything that we were hoping it
would be is exactly what it is right and
that's one of the things to keep in mind
like kevin feige and those guys they
come out and they say stuff like well
you got to make sure you temper
expectations that kind of a thing but to
a degree they also play some games there
where it's like i mean maybe it is maybe
it's not here you just got to go to the
theater and find out so i'm excited man
because obviously foggy can't come out
and just be like all the rumors you've
heard are true guys it's all happening
because then it would basically spoil
the hell out of the movie so he can't
come out and say that so if it really is
all happening then it makes sense that
the answer feige would give is well
people need to temper their expectations
right i can neither confirm nor deny
that the rumors that you have seen on
social media about spider-man no way
home are true right maybe they are maybe
they're not you just got to go see the
movie and find out so regardless whether
it's true or not i will say things like
this build anticipation for spider-man
no way home man it does nothing more
than amp people up to see this movie
more and more so let me know what you
guys think down in the comment section
do you guys think the trailer is real do
you think it's fake do you guys think
it's just one of those fan sort of
things put together and if it is real
and even if it is fake does it get you
more amped up for the movie does it get
you more excited for the release of
spider-man no way home because i got to
tell you guys man
this movie i think is going to smash
records relatively speaking right given
kova in the last year or so you know but
it's going to smash some box office
records it's going to perform insanely
well right like this is going to be one
of those times where people are like i
mean i'm kind of afraid of getting kovid
but i want to see spider-man more so
whatever man and like everybody's going
to go see it
it'll be the first time in a long time
that you see a packed movie theater so
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace